let's talk about what's been happening
in Chile this is a country some people
have described as an economic success
story
but we're also seeing this protesters
angry at not being able to put food on
the table get proper health care and
just generally with how the countries
run so what are they seeing that others
aren't
is there a flipside to chill a success
story whether Chile can be described as
successful depends on who you ask and
ultimately where their politics lie
let's start with a look at Chile's
economy and really any story about the
country's modern economy should start
with these guys the Chicago boys they're
a famous some would say infamous group
of chilean neoliberal economists in the
1970s they studied in Chicago under
Milton Friedman a champion of
free-market capitalism and an eventual
Nobel laureate it was around that time
back in Chile that General Augusto
Pinochet staged a military coup to get
rid of President Salvador Allende and
his socialist government Chile's economy
was a mess yearly inflation was running
around 300 percent and a lot of people
struggled to pay for basic necessities
so Pinochet needed a plan to fix the
economy and the Chicago boys had won it
went like this the best social public
policy is economic growth if the economy
grows you will have less poverty and so
on along the time in thus far Chicago
voice the recommendation was right
Chile's economy did grow thanks to
freeing up the market Chile made trade
deals with countries around the world
exporting things like copper and it's
internationally renowned wines in 2010
Chile even became the first Latin
American country to join the OECD a
Clark for developed economies applause
back-slapping and especially
congratulations were an order at Chile's
presidential palace Chile's economy has
had its bumps but compared to its Latin
American neighbors the country has
become a sort of promised land between
2017 and 2018 Chile's economy grew by
about twenty billion dollars compare
that to Argentina where the economy sure
by a hundred and twenty three billion
dollars in that time
it's no wonder tens of thousands of
migrants from all over South America
have moved to Chile for jobs in the last
few years the leading countries in GDP
per capita we have reduced our poverty
from nearly 40 percent in 1990 to down
28.6% last year so what that rosy
picture in mind it's tough to imagine
why a four cent increase in metro ticket
prices led to the biggest protest in
Chile in years the only people kicked it
off by refusing to pay for the Metro
soon the protests grew and spread the
unrest on the streets of the Chilean
capital and elsewhere in the country has
been unrelenting but it also got ugly
people started burning stuff there was
looting and the government deployed the
military protesters and police
confronted each other thousands were
injured on both sides and people had
died
now this movement has been about a lot
of things but one of the big ones is
inequality 33% of Chilean GDP goes to
the one-percenters that's higher than
almost everywhere I don't think there's
another country has that level of
inequality
well many protesters say is that the
middle class in Chile isn't middle class
at all that's because in the government
size a person can qualify as middle
class even if they earn as little as a
hundred and eighty dollars a month for a
family of four it's about six hundred
and thirty dollars I would be
classifying
amongst the 20 richest percent in the
country and Yee monthly income is about
nine nine fifty euros a month and I'm
rational with a master's degree I don't
think that's a rich person Chile's
National Statistics Institute calculated
that eighty percent of people have no
money left at the end of the month once
they get through paying for food
transport housing and basic services
it's all gone unless they pay for stuff
and installments which in Chile you can
do just about anywhere a lot of people
go to the supermarket with a credit card
they don't even have enough to pay for
that supermarket bill in cash so in a
way we have seen a decrease in poverty
but we have more people in debt the
protesters have another criticism and
that's against high levels of
privatization in Chile utilities like
water and electricity are in the hands
of private companies whereas sectors
like education and health have a mix of
private and public options critics
though say that system is driving prices
up and that the quality of public
offerings are worsening now if a retiree
hasn't paid into a private pension for
instance they get a government allowance
of
one hundred and eighty dollars of them
we have people who are receiving
pensions after a word from their whole
lives which are making them poor they
don't cover their basic needs with a
pension that they are getting access to
good health care that is really
expensive access to private schools
that's really expensive access to some
universities that's really expensive now
in response the Chilean government has
raised the minimum wage promised more
money for health services and the very
elderly but some protesters say won't be
enough and now there's division over
just how much Chile's free-market model
should change there are two perspective
for the crisis in Chile one is Chile's
poor country unequal Society also we
need to change everything the another is
much more social democracy pension funds
the health and so on but we need to keep
the competitiveness of the economy and
that's the government's message yes we
recognize the need for social fairness
but we cannot change things overnight
and also we need to keep a country that
keeps an economy working because if the
discussion is about redistributing
wealth well we first need to create that
world moving ahead won't be easy there's
been damage Chile's National Human
Rights Institute accuses the police and
military of serious abuses that include
using excessive force during the
demonstrations even Chile's famously
stable economy had its biggest drop in a
decade and it's probably not going to
recover for a while but there is a plan
to reconcile the country it involves
rewriting the Constitution that was
originally drafted during Pinochet
dictatorship polls in Chile say it's
something 80% of Chileans seem to
support and so does the president yo
creo que aqui es a sublime a importancia
recuperar el valor de la unidad el
respeto
del V a logo de los acuerdo z-- y de la
buena voluntad con que debemos real
hacen a knows enter nosotros y special
go look appears anything in April a
referendum will ask voters whether they
want a new constitution and whether it
should be written by an alt citizen body
or include lawmakers - if it goes ahead
elections for that body are expected to
happen in October it's gonna be a long
and politically difficult process but
the idea is that Chile can write a news
story if you will a story more people
can call a success if there's a story in
the news or if there's a topic you want
to get your head around get in touch
with us on Twitter Facebook or YouTube
and make sure to subscribe to Algiers
channels and pages so you can't miss our
next episode